bonjour je suis Gwenola bigouin
directrice de l'espace Alphonse d'udé à
coanière aujourd'hui je vais vous donner
trois bonnes raisons d'aller voir le
spectacle champ de
[Musique]
bataille c'est un seul en scène euh qui
aborde l'adolessence et la crise de la
quarantaine c'est donc un spectacle
drôle rythmé et émouvantain matin la
deuxème raison c'est un spectacle
familial les adolescents comme les
adultes s'y retrouveront pourront rire
d'eux-mêmes et de leurs proches donc en
l'occurrence des parents ou des enfants
la troisième raison c'est un spectacle
belge donc un gage de qualité en temps
normal et qui plusé qui a été nominé en
2020 au prix metterling qui sont les
Molières belge nous lui avons pas montré
la mer nous l' avons pas appris à faire
du vélo nous lui avons pas torché le
derrière non
nous sommes arrivés le jour de son 15e
anniversaire pour lui dire de ramasser
ses mouchoirs et de mettre ses slips
dans le bacalage sale un enfant il ne
faudrait jamais lui permettre de
dépasser 12 ans grand maximum après les
emmerdes
commencna
véocé c'était donc les trois bonnes
raisons d'aller voir le champ de
bataille le 17 novembre à 20h45 à
l'espace Alphonse
doudé